et le césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribué à sandrine kiberlain et si
berne avait déjà reçu un césar en 96
solide et meilleur espoir féminin pour
en avoir une paella 5e à réussir le
doublé césar du meilleur espoir césar de
la meilleure actrice après sandrine
bonnaire elodie bouchez sylvie testud et
sa concurrente d'un soir sarah forestier
en 2013 elle a aussi brillé dans les
gamins d'anthony martial nautic club de
serge bozon et violette de martin
provost
on la retrouvera le 26 mars dans aimer
boire et chanter d'alain resnais
mon coeur va lâcher je crois merci du
fond du coeur
c'était pas gagné
les filles j'étais trop fier d'être en
compétition avec vous j'ai senti
beaucoup de bienveillance cette année et
depuis un certain temps et c'est une
année pour moi incroyable je crois que
j'ai squatté à peu près toutes les
productions françaises de l'année
albert
vraiment je je salue ici ton ton talent
sa singularité dans l'originalité
merci d'avoir ce cerveau d'où est sortie
ce film
imparable si réussie que j'adore avec ce
rôle d'ariane que j'ai tellement adoré
jouer merci pour ta confiance ta
bienveillance en exigence
je voudrais je pense à tous les metteurs
en scène qui m'ont qui m'ont aimée qui
m'ont choisie ça fait 20 ans bientôt que
je fais ce enfin que j'ai fait des films
j'aime tellement faire des films avec
vous jouez je crois que c'est là que je
me sens le mieux
en dehors de mon quotidien que j'adore
je vous rassure mais c'est l'endroit où
j'ai plus peur de rien quand j'y crois
je j'ai plus peur du ridicule
donc je pense beaucoup à tous les
metteurs en scène qui m'ont choisie qui
m'ont aimée qui m'ont regardé qui m'ont
comprise qui m'ont donné des très beaux
rôles pendant toutes ces années
j'embrasse très fort claire blondel qui
m'accompagne avec beaucoup de complicité
de passion je crois que kaki maynial
serait très fiers de nous et je
j'embrasse tous les gens que j'aime et
ils savent qu'ils sont et surtout je
dédie mon césar à ma fille suzanne ma
chance
merci infiniment jeu très heureux aussi
j'appelle un président un président qui
a réussi à conserver sa popularité au
cours de cette 39e cérémonie des césars
monsieur françois cluzet
je vais voir un tueur
navré j'ai oublié de dire quelque chose
qui me tient tellement à coeur je
bouscule tout cette cérémonie
je voudrais embrassé très forte
catherine baud organ qui a su persuader
qu est la productrice du film d'albert
et qui a su persuader albert que j'étais
petit et brunes pour jouer cette grande
juge blonde dans le film voilà